(Amy)
Roy had the kids,
so me and Trev--
Oh, great.
We hit the road.
Fun.
Antiquing.
Heaven.
Oh!
Welcome back, home shoppers.
Over the break, we sold 600
Steve Irwin commemorative coins.
600.
Now, this is the perfect
gift for someone
who does not have
a Steve Irwin coin.
God, I miss Steve,
you know?
Yeah, oh yeah.
You know what's
great about him?
He, he--
Everything.
Everything and...
Yeah?
He had the kind of body
where he didn't work out,
but it looked like
he worked out.
Sure!
Got one of these
for my wife.
Your what!?
Okay.
Oh, next up,
what do we have?
Oh!
Oh, boy.
Okay, okay.
Stop.
Now, speaking of
perfect gifts,
now, this is a
no brainer, all right?
Now, this is a gun.
Just your regular,
run of the mill,
meat and potatoes
handgun.
Now, how cute is that?
I love that.
How cute-- we can pick it up?
Look at this.
Oh, heavy, oh...
Ooh, can I see this?
You can hold it, sure.
Oh, wow!
Look at that.
Wow, look at that.
(imitates gun firing)
Wow!
Bam-bam, bam-bam!
It's like a toy,
but it's extremely real.
Yeah, and now here is
what's great about this.
Now, pretty much anyone
can purchase this.
Mm-hmm.
Okay?
Oh, my God, this is so fun,
I love this.
It's fun.
Hey, lady, give me all your
money and your makeup!
(screaming)
(laughing)
Oh, my God, so fun,
and it's on sale now.
Call in.
Oh, we got a caller.
Oh, caller!
(man on phone)
Hey, did I miss
the Steve Irwin coins?
Uh, yeah, you did.
You sure did, honey.
I'm sorry.
But that's okay.
You want a gun?
Oh, no,
I could never get a gun.
I have several
violent felonies.
(both chuckling)
Oh, no.
Caller, you bite your tongue,
you silly goose.
You can absolutely
get a gun
if you have
several felonies,
as long as you buy
it on the Internet...
Right.
...or at a gun show,
and caller, guess where
you are right now?
(siren blaring)
Bam! You're at a gun show!
You're at a gun show.
Yes, if you go to a gun show you
can get an unlicensed seller
to sell you a gun,
no questiones asked.
That's right, not one question
for you, caller.
Great, I'll get one for me
and my mouthy cunt wife.
Ooh, one's for
your wife.
In a way.
Great.
You know the guns my wife
can't get enough of?
These.
You are really committing
to the whole wife thing.
She's real.
What's her name?
Ben...
...ita, Benita.
(with Spanish accent)
From España.
That's fantastic,
and just a reminder
to all the parents at home,
these make perfect
stocking stuffers.
Oh, yeah.
Right?
For-- for as young as--
Beautiful.
It doesn't matter,
okay?
These are great
for any age group.
It's like the bottom
of the stocking.
It is, it's shaped...
It's like the foot.
...very stocking-like.
It's like a metal foot.
Very stocking-like shape, okay?
Fantastic.
My wife's in the states,
by the way.
I said she's Spanish,
but she is from the states.
Let's keep these
calls coming.
We only have
65 million left.
And here's some good news.
Even a blind person can see
what a great deal this is
and take advantage of this
deal by buying a gun.
Totally legal!
So, if you're Stevie Wonder,
you don't have to wonder
if you can get a gun.
Uh, caller, I, I hope you
just called to say
you want a gun.
Stevie Wonder reference.
(chuckling)
My wife's favorite band.
(man with accent on phone)
Hi, I wanted to buy
a lot of these
but I am suspected terrorist
on the no-fly list.
Oh.
Ooh-ooh.
You're fine, sweet potato fries.
You're fine.
The no-fly list.
No one can tell you that
you don't have a right
to buy a gun in this country
you're trying to destroy.
(bell ringing)
You're funny today.
Uh-oh, uh-oh!
Whoa! What is that?
You know what that means.
Mass shooting.
We've had
a mass shooting.
Which means the government
could be coming
for your guns soon,
like they never have,
but always might.
Scary.
Now, we're gonna go
to commercial.
When we come back-- ooh,
you're gonna like this--
we'll be selling United States
Congressmen and Senators
whose influence
can be purchased
for much cheaper
than you think.
Yes, and they're
selling out fast,
ranging from $1,000 to--
(gunshot, screaming)
(Fuck)!
Shh...
Shit!
Ah, ah,
(fuck, fuck)!
Oh! Shit!
It was his foot's time.